Hi. Welcome back.
In the last session, we looked at
arbitrage, where two assets with exactly
identical cash flows trade at different
prices and you lock in the difference.
But we also talked about how it's very
difficult to find, and even when you
find it, it doesn't last that long.
In this session, I want to look at what
I call near arbitrage. In near
arbitrage, what you have are two assets
that have very similar, but not
identical cash flows, but are priced
differently. So it's not quite riskless,
but it's very close to riskless, and you
hope to make a profit that covers even
that mild risk.
So as an example of near arbitrage,
let's take a simple one.
Let's assume you have the same stock
listed in multiple markets, the New York
Stock Exchange and the London Exchange.
They trade at the same price,
and you'd expect them to.
But if they trade at different prices,
you could buy the stock in one exchange
at the lower price, sell it at exactly
the same time at the higher price, lock
in the difference.
So there are two scenarios where this
can happen. One is when you have dual or
multiple listed stocks, and I'll start
with that.
And the second is a more complex example
of depository receipts. What are
depository receipts? This is a foreign
stock that gets listed, let's say in the
US market. It's traded in dollars. It's
not the actual share, but a depository
receipt that gives you rights to the
shares. So there's a process involved in
converting it to shares. But
essentially, it's on the same company.
So let's start with dual listed stocks.
There are many companies that are listed
in multiple markets. Many of the largest
market cap companies, in fact, trade in
multiple markets. And in most of them,
there is no arbitrage opportunity. They
trade at roughly the same price,
especially if they all trade at the same
point in time in the day. Remember with
time differences, exchanges might not be
open. So in the middle of the night,
it's possible that price divergences,
but there's nothing you can do. During
the period where trading is open in both
or more markets, you should expect the
stock to trade at the same price. You're
saying, "What if they're in different
currencies?" Not a big deal, right?
If the price difference is there, you'd
buy it still. You'd buy the cheaper one,
sell the more expensive one, and remove
the currency risk
by converting right away. So, that does
assume you have a convertible currency
that's a freely traded currency.
And doing all of this, you have to make
sure that the profits you make exceed
the transactions cost, because the
deviations are not going to be huge.
Now, when you look at, is there evidence
that people can do it? The studies that
I've seen have usually focused on less
liquid exchanges. One study looked at 84
stocks that were traded on two different
exchanges there.
That traded at different prices, and at
least in paper, the prices deviated by
about 2%. So, you can argue, "Why don't
people make money?"
When the study looked at what would it
would require for you to make money, the
price impact and the trading costs
involved were large enough that they
concluded that while there were price
differences, they were not large enough
to exploit.
So, when you have to do a listed stock,
especially in markets where the
currencies are freely convertible,
I would not expect price differences to
be large and persist, because they're
very quickly going to get traded away.
But maybe you might be the lucky person
who trades them away and makes a profit.
You're saying, "What about depositary
receipts?"
In a depositary receipt, you have a
company from a different market listing
in the US market, but rather than list
their actual shares, they list
depositary receipts.
And they You know, these are called
ADRs, and what ADRs give you is the
right to 10 shares of Tata Motors, an
Indian company, and you can buy the
shares in dollars. And US investors like
it, because they're trading in dollars
through the US exchange. And as a bonus,
companies list ADRs often have to
restate their financials so that you can
see what the numbers would look like
using US GAAP.
The one catch though is these ADRs, even
though in they are technically the
equivalent to local shares, there's a
conversion process that can be
complicated or even overwhelmingly
difficult to get through. But you'd
expect an ADR and the local shares to
trade at roughly equivalent prices
assuming you've corrected for units.
If you look at ADRs in the US, there are
some mark some country ADRs where the
price of the ADR and the price of the
stock are effectively the same. But in
for countries like India where you have
an ADR listed for an Indian company, the
prices can not just be different but
very different. Often 30, 50, 60% more
expensive to buy an Indian company ADR
than it is to buy the domestic listing.
You're saying, "Well, why can't I take
advantage of that mispricing?"
Well, a big chunk of that mispricing you
you know, maybe it's because you're you
know, people overreact to the US market
and they you know, what I mean by that
is the US market is down 10%. They might
be marking down the Indian stock by 10%
even though it doesn't deserve to.
But the bigger problem is that
convergence might never happen. You
might buy the the domestic listing, sell
the ADR and hope to make money on the
convergence happening. But if it doesn't
happen, you're not going to earn any
excess returns.
Maybe in the long term it does in which
case a longer time horizon can help.
You're saying, "Why might convergence
not happen?"
No, for a good number of different
reasons. One is we talked about
converting ADRs to shares is not
necessarily easy to do. Then you might
have exchange rate issues when you try
to convert currency. So multiple real
world concerns can keep keep ADRs priced
differently than local listings.
So that's
dual listings and why they might not or
might be the basis for near arbitrage.
Another place where you can try near
arbitrage is closed-end mutual funds.
Closed-end mutual fund is like a regular
mutual fund in the sense that it invests
in publicly traded companies.
But unlike regular mutual funds when you
send money into the fund, the number of
units in the fund just expands to fill
the extra money. With a closed-end
mutual fund, the stock is actually
traded. The fund itself is traded. So
there's a market value for the fund
which is different from the sum of the
market values of the companies that are
in that fund.
You could argue that if closed-end
mutual funds trade at a price less than
the value of the securities that they
own,
that's an arbitrage, right? Because you
should be able to buy the company,
liquidate the stocks, and keep the
difference.
Here's a reality check.
Most closed-end funds trade at discounts
that are pretty significant, 10, 15, 20%
on the value of the assets in play.
There are a few that trade at a premium
and we talked about why that might be
when we talked about Berkshire Hathaway.
But you're saying, why wouldn't I be
able to exploit these discounted
closed-end funds and keep the
difference? Let's talk about some
practical issues here.
One is there are times when closed-end
funds do unlock the discount by
open-ending. But it's a gradual process.
It's not like you make money overnight
because the process has to play out.
So when you do see the the uh the the
these closed-end funds are open and the
discount does disappear. But in
practical terms, here are the two issues
that might actually keep you from being
able to profit from that discount.
The first is remember, to exploit the
difference, you got to be able to buy
the closed-end fund and liquidate the
stock.
Well, buying the closed-end fund and
getting control of it can become an
issue because there might be the the way
it's structured, where it's listed, how
it's incorporated, the corporate
governance might be such you might not
be able to take over the fund even as
you buy a bigger and bigger stake on the
fund. The second is once you buy the
fund and you take control, when you go
to sell the shares in the fund, remember
there are two things to deal with. One
is in the process of selling those
shares, you might affect the price.
There might be a price impact, pushing
the price down. And second, if you are
selling these shares at a price much
higher than the price you bought them
at,
there's a capital gain on which you got
to pay taxes. We talked a little bit
about this earlier in the context of
transactions cost.
But closed-end funds look like arbitrage
opportunities
on paper, but in practice, it's actually
very difficult to make money off that
discount.
But there's a more nuanced play you can
make on closed-end funds.
You look at the discount in closed-end
funds. The discounts vary across
closed-end funds. Some dis- Closed-end
funds are discounted by 10%, 15, 20, 25,
30. Some are discounted by 50%.
So what this study looked at was the
most discounted and the least discounted
funds and tracked the discounts over
time.
And it discovered mean reversion, that
things move towards an average, which
means the most discounted funds have
their discounts decrease, the least
discounted funds see their discounts go
up.
This is clearly not arbitrage. It's an
investment opportunity where you buy the
most discounted funds, you sell short on
the least discounted funds and you try
to make money on that, not convergence,
the
the lessening of the divergence across
the funds.
In a related um
issue,
there's this there's this phenomenon
called a holding company a conglomerate
discount. A holding company is basically
a company that is composed of
individual companies that are brought
into a a entity.
In many cases, the individual companies
are publicly traded, have their own
market value, and the holding company
discount reflects the fact that if you
take a holding company and look at the
holdings it has,
and you take the market value of those
holdings and you add them up, like
closed-end funds,
holding companies often trade at a
discount on the market value of their
holdings,
especially if they're publicly traded.
Now, of course, this then looks like
arbitrage, right? You should be able to
buy the holding company and sell off
those holdings and keep the difference.
So, let's see what keeps the holding
company discount intact and why it might
not be so easy to exploit.
Holding company discounts are often very
common with family group companies.
India is a is a classic example of
holding groups, which are family groups,
composed of
that family groups' individual companies
that are each publicly traded. So, the
holding company owns shares in the
family's other companies that are all
publicly traded, and the holding company
trades at a significant discount.
This study actually, which looked at
Indian holding company discount,
chronicles a pretty amazing discount.
The average discount is 50, 60, 70%, but
there are outliers. But if you even look
at the median discount,
you get 30 to 40% discounts.
This seems like a
a way in which we can make money, right?
Because if you have a holding company
trading at a 40% discount
on the individual companies that are
embedded in it, you think, why does that
even happen in the first place? I can
point to six reasons why I think holding
company discounts exist. First is maybe
it's just a market mistake. Maybe the
market screws up, but it's a pretty big
mistake, right? Cuz the assets are
publicly traded, you can observe them.
The second
possibility is there's a one of the
holdings, one of the companies that the
holding company owns is contaminating.
The contamination effect is affecting
the rest.
In other words, you have a tobacco
company in that holding company group
and it's being sued by people and
potentially could face very large
payments out. It could affect the value
of the other holdings. There's an
efficiency story, especially at for
conglomerates, that if you spread
yourself too thin, you try to run all
these different businesses, you might
not run them efficiently and the market
is incorporating
into the discount.
There's a simplicity story, which is
valuing publicly traded holding
companies is a nightmare. You're valuing
15 companies put together with different
growth growth rates and risk and cash
flows. So, you might just say, "Look,
I'm going to discount the company
because of its complexity."
There might be a tax story,
which is this holding company discount
reflects the fact that if you, you know,
that that that that the holding company
pays more in taxes than the income
generated than by the subsidiaries as
stand-alone.
And finally, there's a corporate
governance issue. As I mentioned, a lot
of these holding companies are
controlled by families and the family is
so in control that you can never ever
take control of the businesses embedded.
So, what investors do? They mark down
the holding company price.
Now, if you think about how can I get
past this and make money in the holding
company discount? Let's look at
strategies.
One is um
you assume that you will never control
the holding company, never liquidate the
companies, but you assume that over
time, especially with some market
mistake, that the discount will get
smaller.
That the company run So, basically,
you're buying the holding company
because it's so massively discounted,
hoping the discount gets smaller.
Clearly not arbitrage, but an investment
strategy nevertheless.
The second is the holding company is
reaching a trigger point where it might
actually try to unlock the discount by
spinning off its holdings.
Why would the holding company do it?
Because the family is reaching a tipping
point where the patriarch of the family
used to control the family
is passing on and the next generation so
we like to make a lot more money. They
want to unlock the discount. So you
divest, you spin off, and you unlock.
The third is an activist investor has
entered the picture. And sometimes this
activist might be from within the family
taking effective control and doing the
same thing, divesting and spinning it
off.
It's very difficult for an outsider to
do it, but if you can get an insider to
do it, you can take advantage of that
discount decreasing if not disappearing
over time.
And there are costs to consider, which
is as you start to to divest or
liquidate these holdings, there might be
a liquidity effect where you get less
than what you thought you would get when
you first looked at those holdings.
Again, tax issue, just like you had with
close you know, which is when you
divest, you got to pay capital gains
taxes.
This I mentioned the corporate
governance barriers can be so steep and
so difficult to get over that you
finally give up. The cost of getting
over them exceeds the benefits of taking
over the company and breaking it up.
One final example of near arbitrage is
what's called convertible arbitrage.
Convertible arbitrage comes about when
you have a company that has shares and
bonds issued issuing convertible bonds.
You think, where is the arbitrage? You
got shares issued with a market price.
You got traditional straight bonds
issued with a bond price. Now you issued
convertible bonds. Remember a
convertible bond is in effect a
combination of an equity option,
an option to convert to equity, and a
straight bond.
It has to be tied to how equity the
price of the equity and the price of the
straight bond, right? But once in a
while you can have
bonds trading at a price where you can
effectively create something that looks
like the convertible bond using the
equity and the straight bonds of the
company
and capture the difference. It's called
convertible arbitrage. It's messy,
right? You know, because there are
things that might not exist for you to
get the arbitrage. One is if you don't
have straight bonds, if all you have are
convertible bonds,
getting the arbitrage or a near
arbitrage can be tough to do. Second is
forcing conversion of convertible bonds,
which is sometimes required on these
strategies, might not be feasible. They
can reap wreak havoc, you know,
especially if companies force
conversion.
Now,
thirdly, if convertible bonds have long
maturities, there might be no
convergence for a long period before the
convergence happens. So, you're holding
and holding and holding and nothing
happens. Eventually, you might make
profit, but you need a long time
horizon. And finally, there can be
transactions costs, especially on small
companies that have all three of these
listed.
So, let's review. For convertible
arbitrage, you need stocks which have
both shares listed, straight bonds
listed, and convertible bonds.
And if they do and they're mispriced
relative to each other, it is
conceivable you can lock in profits with
a residue of risk. It's not completely
riskless and a near arbitrage.
So, if you decide to go this route of
near arbitrage, what do you need first?
This is a philosophy for bigger
investors. So, if you have 100,000 or a
million, it's not going to work for you.
But you have a billion or 10 billion and
you're trying to You need a lot of
capital because many of these strategies
are built on small pricing differences
and you need to keep transactions costs
low and trade quickly. You might need a
lot of capital to do it. Second, it
helps if you can force convergence, if
you can act as a catalyst. So, if you're
trying to unlock the holding company
strategy, rather than being a passive
investor in a holding company
discounted. If you can put pressure on
the company to divest, to spin off, it
does help. So, having those catalysts,
either provided by you or by somebody
outside, can help you make money. So,
you need capital, you need convergence,
you need catalysts.
And if you can pull that off,
your arbitrage might might not deliver
riskless profits like pure arbitrage
does, but it might be easier to find on
the ground.
I hope you found this session useful,
and I thank you very much for listening.